Speaker 1: . Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am a substitute teacher, Jesse Dolma.
Yesterday, as a matter of follow up, I talked
about Rand Paul on a video he put on YouTube
that was just filled to the brim with antiscience
propaganda, anti mask rhetoric coming to arrest
us.
They can't arrest us all, he said.
And it got him suspended.
Got his YouTube temporarily suspended by YouTube.
I'm going to read from the New York Times
article talking about it, and then we're going
to hear the brave man of action, Rand Paul's
response on Twitter.
YouTube suspends Rand Paul for a week over
video disputing the effectiveness of masks.
Now, listen.
In the time, the time in which we're living
through a pandemic for fear going on two years
now.
Where we have been holed up in our houses,
if you're taking it seriously and and then
this new norm of wearing masks to protect
one another, it is a strange time and it's
the weakest among us.
Morally weak, ethically weak, mentally weak
among us like Rand Paul, who insist on pushing
back against mass mandates, when the CDC has
said clearly with with with study after study
after study that they prevent the spread,
they slow the spread.
It's not it's not an ultimate prevention that,
yes, it's over.
You'll never get covered if you wear a mask.
But absolutely, it's a mitigation effort.
Reading from this New York Times article,
YouTube on Tuesday removed a video by Senator
Rand Paul of Kentucky for the second time
and suspended him from publishing for a week
after he posted a video that disputed the
effectiveness of wearing masks to limit the
spread of the coronavirus.
Now, if you'd like to watch the video.
You watch the full David Pakman show program
or the isolated clip when it's posted, but
I posted and played a lot of it reacted to
it, a YouTube representative said the Republican
senators claims in the three minute video
had violated the company's policy on covid-19
medical misinformation.
The company policy bans videos that spread
a wide variety of misinformation, including
claims that masks do not play a role in preventing
the contraction or transmission of covid-19
we apply.
This is YouTube.
We apply our policies consistently across
the platform, regardless of speaker or political
views, and we make exceptions, as in the case
of my talking about it yesterday.
And we make exceptions for videos that have
additional context, such as countervailing
views from local health authorities, the representative
said in a statement.
In the video, Mr. Paul says, quote, Most of
the masks you get over the counter don't work.
They don't prevent infection, end quote.
Later in the video, he adds, quote, Trying
to shape human behavior isn't the same as
following the actual science, which tells
us that cloth masks don't work.
And quote, In fact, masks do work.
According to the near unanimous recommendations
of public health experts, the CDC, it said
in November that wearing face masks reduced
the spread of the virus and that, quote, individual
benefit increases with increasing community
mask use.
And a study aboard the USS Theodore Roosevelt
indicated that 70 percent decrease in transmission
just from wearing masks.
What is Rand Paul doing?
To what truth is he obligated?
He is supposedly.
A man of science who is supposedly a doctor
and this is the way he responded on Twitter.
A badge of honor, left wing Cretans at YouTube
banning me for seven days for a video that
quotes to peer reviewed articles saying cloth
masks don't work.
If you want to see the band video, go to Liberty
Tree.
And he promotes some.
Ding dong.
Free speech websites, you'd like to see the
video.
I play a little bit of it and react to it.
That's where you go.